fabien schaeffer merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france
votre réaction au discours prononcé par
joe biden cette nuit ils ne revendiquent
pas sa victoire mais il dit qu'il va
gagner et que l'écart se creuse écoutez
je suis je peux me féliciter qu'ils
soient prudents
sous l'oeil attentif de madame kamala
harris représentante des crozes intérêts
des gaffes à tout le monde reste très
prudent parce que je pense qu'ils savent
qu'il ya un enjeu juridique très
important qui va se profiler dans les
semaines à venir
comment expliquer ce changement enfin
ces deux stratégies différentes un
donald trump joe biden joe biden attend
la fin des résultats où dit il est
prudent ou au moins il attend d'avoir
les 270 grands électeurs pour annoncer
sa victoire et l'actuel locataire de la
maison blanche lui est plus offensif il
annonce la victoire alors qu'il n'était
il ya deux cent quatorze grands
électeurs il évoque des fraudes sans
apporter de preuve pourquoi de deux
stratégies différentes
alors d'abord là vous avez deux
affirmations que j'aimerais rectifier
tout de suite la première c'est qu'il ne
déclare pas sa victoire il dit que pour
tous les votes qui sont légaux il était
en avance et deuxièmement je ne crois
pas ce qui empêche un candidat de
pointer du doigt des fraudes massives et
je vous rectifie là aussi nous avons des
éléments de preuve et nous avons surtout
des éléments juridiques vous parlez de
la pennsylvanie la cour suprême de
pennsylvanie à modifier la loi
électorale de cette étape pour autoriser
des votes arrivant bien plus tard que le
jour normalement autorisés etc ce sujet
là qui va remonter à la cour suprême
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que il a été
demandé à l'état de pennsylvanie de
s'assurer que les bulletins de vote qui
sont arrivés postérieurement au
au jour de vote le 3 novembre soit
distingué des autres bulletins de vote
est-ce que c'est donc une demi victoire
pour pour donald trump par rapport à
cette annonce un de la cour suprême
justement sur les bulletins de vote qui
vont être séparés ceux qui sont arrivés
après le 3 novembre à ce que c'est une
demi-victoire et est ce que c'est le
temps finalement que donald trump
cherche cherche à gagner ce que c'est
laisser son allié
écoutez je ne parle même pas d'une
victoire de tram je pense que c'est une
victoire pour les institutions
d'ailleurs bill burton l'attorney
général
c'est peut-être dire pour vous auditeurs
de ministre de la justice américaine
avait déjà annoncé au mois de septembre
dans une interview qu'il y avait des
irrégularités des problèmes qu'il savait
déjà ce qui allait se produire parce que
dès que vous autorisez le fait que des
bulletins peuvent arriver
postérieurement intérieurement pardon à
la fermeture des bureaux de vote il ya
des risques de fraude et là il ya aussi
d'autres enquêtes qui sont lancés par le
fbi avait parlé police on a appris ce
matin que le chef de cabinet de la
maison blanche venait d'être testé
positif aux cocos vie de 19 de ses
collaborateurs seraient également
concernées on sait que donald trump a
déjà été malade le corps n'a virus plus
que jamais au coeur de ces élections de
cette élection plutôt est ce que donne
30 n'a pas trop mis de côté ses thèmes
durant la campagne alors que 127 mille
nouveaux cas viennent d'être détectée
alors tout d'abord il faut distinguer
les cas asymptomatiques des cas
symptomatiques je crois que c'est un
problème majeur dans la lah la façon
dont on aborde cette crise du coc vide
je pense que trump a martelé que il
avait pour but nous libérer d'un
confinement éternelle que nous promet
l'équipe hayden d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est le sujet qui fait trembler
beaucoup d'américains nous n'avons pas
envie de rester confinés dans le sous
sol des maisons de nos parents des
cadors du parti républicain comment cela
se passe des sols est désolidarisée
pardon de donald trump comme mitt romney
par exemple fox news
sans me prendre un petit peu ses
distances également des chaînes ont même
coupé son discours comment les
républicains en france juge l'attitude
de donald trump
accusé par certains médias de répandre
de fausses d'informations dans votre
question il ya deux points si vous
parlez des vieux loups de l'équipe bush
des années 2000 et notamment monsieur me
trotte mais où jacques rogge karl rove
j'invite mes auditeurs à se renseigner
un petit peu sur le cv de ces messieurs
je pense que c'est l'arrière garde du
parti républicain qui n'a jamais
vraiment accepté la première élection de
trump mai mais en france comment est ce
que cela est perçu vous êtes membre des
républicaines serveur si france donc
comment est-ce que tout cela est perçu
dans l'hexagone et coûté pour nous
regarder la différence d'âge entre
l'équipe de c2c vieux loup et nous enfin
je veux dire il ya une génération qui
est arrivé il ya un renouvellement 30
pas modifier la démographie et la
sociologie du parti républicain et en
même temps en face c'est très
intéressant de remarquer que parti
démocrate est complètement vieillissant
n'a pas voulu accepter la montée d'une
jeune génération qui a massivement voté
pour bernie sanders dans leurs primaires
et il s'accroche au pouvoir comme des
mollusques ruetschi nancy pelosi veut
encore faire un autre mandat et
d'ailleurs les caciques du parti
démocrate commence à lui dire écoute et
il serait peut-être temps de se
renouveler je veux dire que c'est
manifeste un moment tout système à un
besoin de se renouveler
elle fait que 50% des tweets de tron est
preuve depuis le 3 novembre
elle était supprimé ça vous évoque quoi
on fait ça c'est ça c'est la pratique
d'un système totalitaire je veux dire
que twitter devrait avoir honte de ce
type de de pratique notamment pour un
président des états unis je veux dire
qui a le qui peut se permettre de jouer
à la fois le support technologique et le
juge qui a 100 sur les les déclarations
des membres de ce réseau ou twitter est
un support technologique et liberté
d'expression qui parce que les gens pour
se poursuivre individuellement pour
diffamation
leur twitter est un censeur et à ce
moment là il n'y a plus aucun intérêt
pour des américains d'exercer leur leur
lit gravité lors des et de faire des
déclarations sur ce support twitter est
finie merci vanessa bière schaeffer
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes membre des
repubblica overseas france